in a 1vs1 post plant overtime of an
elimination match and convict might get
the upper hand take your time take your
time injury and overtime that is bull
why would you do that that is only nice
people you know what guys sometimes you
just don't give a [ __ ] I'm calling for
the score eSports and this week on best
of we're talking about no-holds-barred
no [ __ ] given csgo plays Wow so what is
a no place you can play in csgo
well it's pulling your knife out when
you really know you shouldn't it's
sticking that ninja defuse when you
probably should have just tried to save
the gun it's pushing a wall of smokes
with nothing but a cz and a dream so
let's get it started with the most
disrespectful of them all the knife kill
in a 1vs1 post plant over time of
elimination
[Music]
should find the kill on to MSL close
range on config he's on the prowl
you'll be relocating up trying to give
his position away until the shore kill
is they may be playing with his food at
this point he's gonna be fighting this
period absolutely who the police been on
the headshotted know this could be a
knife on the bomb and just rubbing salt
in the wound so he's more safe hit my
workout what a play from him but bialy
he still fixing up to kick there he'll
recover it but Chris J that was no need
of effort it's gone Wow I actually
thought with the timing that he had that
seven seconds ryan's device bit of extra
damage going in for the kill pulls out
the knife oh he gets annoyed for a way
to end that standoff excellent stop
there NOP win the pistol in the most
remarkable of ways something just find
one fragment man Chris Shay's been doing
it
oh the leap in life I think I think I'll
go one further in the salutation for
simple I think he's professor or dr.
simple dr. simple yeah I think that's
probably fair he's summoned his PhD
pretty huge dick I want a bullet from a
knife skadoodle what's he doing a double
night can you get the third he gets the
red clicking yes stewey
the bombs not for and they may not have
the kick player on the bomb so Jay guess
what sir the smoke down was doing he's
gone for the night he's gonna go for and
he does it's to eat he might find this
punch and he goes again for more it's
trading back and forth but it's doing he
finds the clutch he finds a round and
cloud nine with a second pistol is he
gonna try and go huge here
make it three now be be good for one
three on two overalls Dewey I know what
just happened I couldn't tell you I have
no idea but it's nuts
is it safe but guys you know how it is
sometimes you get locked behind the wall
of smokes and your brain says chill but
your heart whispers push it well smoke
goes down he's on the other side of it
could make something of this you know
they're all three players are waiting
for me to the post fool how is this
gonna go down this is insane
against Edward planted smoke in that
wall he goes out
keeping me alive show me you got some
bad Cornish thinking cloud9 might be in
this with a shout they've got guns
grabbed an m4 blossom in the mp9 that
also got nothing going through the smoke
with a tec-9 he's gonna win the round on
his own debris with the secondary or
purse still money available here the
teamliquid
three match points now I honestly would
be surprised
Stan was able to stay in that corner and
go for an immediate defuse aleshia's
faces device there from connector and
I'll joules him of the m4 not even a
headshot the balls on that guy to even
consider that challenge and all of a
sudden came crashing down still a lot of
work to do here you put a shutdown sk
with the four spike pillows you have
these deagles and PP 5000 running the
corner for the calm down you're gonna
die how do you end that so what are
these doing halide answers back but it
is gonna be a four and four what about
Philippe madmen have had the defuse and
see where he peeks from a man spotted
him yet those of steel from copy this is
twice he's been in a1 b2 rate hasn't
peaked it he knows they've tapped it
this time knows they're likely to hold
it talks to quote so the AWP and Gaby
what a clutch back they had no idea that
he was there and absolute nerves of
steel
[Music]
okay what's up the rumble you broke up
deaf arrest on Levin highlight yam as we
saw her got himself a free shot on -
nothing really already lift it now the
flash burns to go out and look at this
is free for nothing
three fast kills depending which way to
look at it simple actually gonna look to
see you some aggression and you'll get
just that snap he loses his head you
know jumping on that defuse when a
Molotov inferno rages beneath you
when bullets are whizzing past your head
might be stupid it might be risky but
hey you gotta get on that highlight reel
somehow am i right
I should shop in a pet Muhammad's death
let's go to Valhalla guy ladies a
McCafferty moment she latashia forget
specifically pom pom is about one
another all contact by a positron Arunta
mr. nadir - sparrow are less active all
day near some of it is south carrucha
palaka yet the knock door not likely
sense not a feed bubbled up so bravely
from a huge deficit box on the prowl
around the forum once the second Frank
and he's got a kid as well this comes
down and suddenly the next bullet could
very well sum up this map he still he go
for the full defuse he's gonna go for
the peak right now steel device around
the world we go over the diffuse the
diffuse is coming in as
[Music]
that is how to control your nerves in
the situation don't it out but my god
Rob wattage approach of snacks uh no not
some tequila motion is the exact right
there is no no solution at all no
solution is nee Molotov Friday new shops
urge this movement the food bomba no
now's a signal PC port of Prince pin
applause as a promise I'll free burger
oh you're you're accomplished it'll
Molotov melodia to pass waking second of
subdues papaya trees or the option to
have skeletal take a cheeky buggers oh
you cheeky bugger
no oh okay I can't make too much noise
your guardian is he realizing this
Guardian what's going on Wow
the bomb is ticking inside the science
seized holding him on the bomb site and
ever coming out behind perfect timing to
drop happy and that means it's gonna be
all on NDK he sneaking in checking every
caller fine C's takes him out he's got
nothing there's no smoke or anything
he's gonna hold it down underhand throw
a flashbang to one second
he's feeding himself a very tight angle
the now on buses to a really weird move
for MBK he jumps up on the Bombers head
boxes and gives his head towards
Showtime there won't be one happy
everything the playful has got decent
position on the water bomb spraying but
a smoke thinks it diffuses coming in can
show up do this it would be a
three-on-one situation to secure the
game here going for the 40 views
happening
it's no time let's go he's somehow
defuses the bomb and it's gonna be happy
dropping that round three versus one pay
for the bomb Thailand be because they
don't have this personnel who yeah they
want this down and the six is alone now
of DWP now he has to peak Oh interesting
situation yes there it is it's the bomb
[Music]
longest reloaded the game boy sitting
him with all that's so sick he got it
well we got it today so that is balls of
I don't even that was one of the most
ridiculous one anyone's I've ever seen
Kerrigan does know that nothing's coming
from there but it looks like actually
it's also checking monster and that
carries shuts him down the stem he's in
with a parcel on there on to cific
somehow pipes a head shot and an ak-47
and a smoke grenade gets the kit as well
so he's got a pod - oh if he could just
go for the whole bit
oh my god Kerrigan is so far away
through this
[Applause]
another play that so I could have done
potentially would be to go in ER and
then run all the way to ladder I think
that look and a little bit riskier but I
mean at that at that stage there's no
real like good play that's why I can
make there it's like he's got a pink one
of like three options right and he's
gonna stake the bunker action this is
actually pretty smart
oh my god oh my word that pulls the
steal the KITT clutch plays are the
stuff of magic and csgo and attempting
one is risky as hell but sometimes those
cocky creative attempts can pay off in
the end and win your team around another
smoke so it could be really rough for
simple tanks to get through this just
just for new viewers the game sometimes
you will see someone throwing their
pistol to pretend it's a grenade to have
people turn around
what do you think it was gonna be a nest
right coming in with a missile from the
sky was people actually doing all its
gonna try and walk back in as they both
get close enough rain considering up or
has a Lugo look brilliant ballin can't
be aggressive but he does still find a
kill as charity for back well this could
be more than one somebody gets caught
out your big shape are furthest bump big
tents in the open good response and he's
picked up the bomb to a 1vs1 and rather
than plant that he's gonna go on date J
all the round of the weekend 72 per
venue full versus water yeah this
McIlwain is knows he done it
that's so sick everyone is eviscerated
by fun believe me he thought Tyler might
have a chance to break them down and get
back into the rounds forget it
mas jabo pain if Turner cardigans
Callisto Grenada guns were left by their
TPA Chavez aye Mitchell avoid pristine
of the blood level Sileo Isla de sitios
de la da at the process the tear away
alia Kapoor will drive versions of the
team but there is a push on the beach -
a Spanish book was also 17 outside it's
gonna be the recipient it's gonna be eco
that's a big frag
but simple is creeping they see with
York now and the disparate play into
becomes inner smokes
just as much in the same place
they this this is ridiculous because
simple is gonna get aggressive as well
oh my god oh my god
fight fire with fire you don't have a
gun catch them up when they least expect
it how does he do that and he might get
a 3-1 oh my goodness information where
the next player is this is fantastic
named Akasha there it is you can spot
the next place oh my god Pasha how did
how did they not us just unbelievable
[Music]
[Music]
and the full market instruments from all
different sites yes another for himself
there is a cake stone those yeah if you
take cells layer in towards the hook now
if these ever the dropsies the very
winnable get mo they win this one anyone
see is the oh my god he runs through the
mouth of and hits the noscope alright
guys that's all we got for you this week
if you've got a suggestion for a player
a team or an event you want us to cover
on best of let me know in the comments
below and I'll see you next week but
until then remember when it comes to
delivering quality content to you the
viewer we really do give up thanks for
watching if you want more great content
just like this be sure to hit the
subscribe button